yeah I read it in college I went to Oral
Roberts University it's been
particularly interesting as an actor
recommend this because especially
studying we work a lot off of a partner
and we really should be like strive to
find a truth with another partner on
state and so working with a robot who's
not necessarily the most humanoid robot
out there it's been interesting to
discover what impulses like a reaction
in me and like how and how to play that
with someone that's not that's not
necessarily what I'm used to playing off
my primary role has been kind of a
technical leader of the personal
robotics lab team that was trying to
convert her from this research platform
into a into an actor in some sense the
theater is one of the highest demanding
demos you can do because there's a live
audience there's tremendous pressure to
make it actually work on time Sam French
the director asked me we've worked
together on a number of other projects
so interesting and I had no idea what to
expect I was very very excited bigger
surprises I thought there would be less
human interaction in building her
because there's me a robot instead of a
human actor but actually there's been
more human interaction based on all the
roboticists who have helped with him
although everyone creating his character
the others people working on his voice
including an actor there's people
working on his movements there's all
sorts of humans creating one non-human
character
labels are not important exactly take me
for example I mean what does it matter
if I have two point three point four
point ecology where my name company
Pittsburgh Cleveland he is a person is
what he is a person is what the primary
challenge is really one of discourse
it's basically getting the actor and
Stan French's the director to come in
and help teach the lab team how to
approach drama and how to think about
drama even from the very basic questions
the lab teams assume that
so the roboticist ended to assume that
like a gesture we carry a specific
emotion but in in the drama school they
teach the students I understand now that
it's not like the single gesture that
carries a single emotion or a single
story it's really that is jesters in
context you know most interesting
partner was trying to take a non robot
then find blue things in it without
emphasizing language to create a visual
vocabulary kind of Kinetico category if
herb as a robot helper an assistant is
going to engage with people we need to
examine now the narratives of just
really a daily life and I think that the
drama is is taking it to one extreme
where it's explicitly about storytelling
with a fixed text and it sort of takes
all those elements and pushes them to
one level but if we can take any of
those elements of storytelling that work
them back into just the way that herb
approaches a person in the kitchen or
the hallway I think that'll be a great
lesson